thank you so that's why i like to sex
organizers for giving me this
opportunity for presiding over work so
so today i'm going to talk about some
analyzes on the topological properties
of the gene regulatory networks will
human cell types in network of biology
we know cell is modeled by a network
this network cable metabolic network or
protein-protein interaction network of
the gene regulatory networks or other
type of network so each cell state is a
vector so basically for each protein
there's a number numerical number of
putting known values so they each cell
type k be considered as a dynamical
systems governor by sight of functions
so that also we need to consider the
input functions there is X no external
signal for the each cells in their multi
multi cell systems so maybe we never
know what these functions are but one
thing is for sure so that is that the
dynamical properties of sale systems but
closely relate to the topological
properties of the networks so so that is
why the people study the topological
features of the supporting networks some
people say the degree distribution skill
free for the protein protein networks
about some people don't agree these
they're also the people care about these
the network motives so we know the
motives
is a very important concept in study the
sequence comparison by the 200 to the
our loans group it just started to study
the network motives so so the reported I
today said of there are several motives
were over-represented in transcriptional
regulator networks the another multi
feedback loop is underrepresented in the
transcriptional regulatory networks but
interesting so that recently this paper
in 2014 this group which is a study this
factor from the quality work stability
point of view ok so today I will preside
over work in the analysis of the
difference in regulatory interactions
between the human cells and tissues they
also are simple analyzes about the
hierarchical organizer organization of
the transcriptional factor regulatory
networks of human cell tissues in the
third part we present some formulas for
the motive account for the general and
TF regulatory networks also the pbi
networks so that the data site we use is
from this paper 2012 sell paper in the
paper the 41 cell tissue specific TF
regulatory networks are for him were
reported so the networks
a divided into these eight categories so
each Network has about 475 transcription
factors quarter of the transcription
factors for human and are they are by
1100 regulatory interactions surgery so
this networks were derived from the DNA
cipher to pray the data and the predict
the by the wedding site yeah I know it's
a regulatory interactions sorry yeah
yeah I just targets with your energy No
adjust the transcriptional factors are
within this transcription factors so the
in the first a soda this is this is a to
a cluster result the first one is from
this paper an F user original paper so
this resort is based on the note degree
vectors of the internet works as super
the right why I was done by us busy we
use the note degree vector of a
subnetwork around the six standard
proteins so basically here we only
consider the information whether protein
is a downstream target of the stent
proteins or not so it's but this is you
you can see the two result of a quite
similar but actually in terms of the
Randy index so over result is slightly
better so this is the quite surprising
then we taste the weather is the tool
for a small subset of randomly selected
the proteins and out actually this
result the shows is the true of almost
four also a small south side
so therefore we can see so they see this
may suggest that the we're very around
the field transcranial factors could
distinguish the the cell identity while
so if we compare the studies of
these two studies so that we can see the
41 cell-specific transcriptional
regulatory networks are different
globally as well as a locally so this is
the analysis the first part the second
part is so basically we analyzes the
hierarchical organization of human
transferrin factor networks so we use a
very simple highbridge reported in this
work I think it territories is one of
the ulcers so
so this is the average pictures on
average the twenty-three percent of the
transcription factors or on the top
layer there's a as many as sixty seventy
percent of transcription factors in the
middle layer there a small amount of
transcription factors in bottom layers
then this this is the age distribution
yes is the agri is a base on the
topological salty Israel
so also AC so compared with the other
cell types of the the embroidery stem
cell has much less transcription factor
in the top layer but much more
transcription factors in the corn ears
so this result is from the the jockeys
paper the original paper so this is over
analyzes that you compare this you can
see this that the existed distance
appear between the human least the
transcription factor networks so she
also we did the summer originated also
depletion analysis of hop transcription
factors also essential also sleeping
transcription factors there so this is
the result basically this is no surprise
as older there are many many hops in the
call layers there are no many hops in
the he neither the top layer and all the
bottom layers so this is a but this is a
lead to be surprised at the hay so it
for the is essential transcranial factor
you see that the troof distribution is
quite revealing something like this now
this is horse keeping transcription
factors and so we have this reason they
also we did the analyzer on the
regulatory interactions specific to the
stem cells so there we also ask exam the
enrichment of interesting transcription
factors also so this is a result i will
talk about these they this is the first
part of the the work so the third party
is about accounting
motives for the network's so giving that
the existing regulatory interaction data
are incomplete or noisy so this is the
question is what are the size of the
entire transmission regulatory networks
of the cell type now how many times does
the motive gear in the entire network so
we there are many papers about this
motive count but we proach this problem
in the following citing so basically we
saw this we are giving incomplete and
noisy data so with these parameters the
spurious link read the missing link rita
also we know the number of an odor in
this is this sub network also the number
of note in the entire network so the
question we ask is how to estimate the
encourages of the motive in the entire
network so
for the as error free sub network data
the estimator actress is a very simple
so we assume I'm is a motive with AB
note the G is internet worker with a
note that this is the experimental data
so this is a they're in so this is some
network that we observe this many
currencies of the motive so they this is
the estimator for us for the motive
account for the entire network so this
is a very simple this is observed number
it just give up by these factors the
factor is independent of the network
motives but this is just a generalized
sort of this formula appearing in these
paper so actually over so we are
motivated by this work so here this
looks are very symbols or so but we can
prove that this one this estimate
actually is is consistently unbiased so
there is basically we assume this is the
the sub network is obtained by a
uniformly selecting note each with this
probability there is a being of these
rituals last estimator / the true County
is equal Y minus this this number less
because the M is a fixed it's a smaller
so that this is a very small number so
so does this is this we have this proves
we also prove something about varies of
these these ratios but we cannot prove
this for up three motives we also did
some simulation analysis about these
regions
but for the incomplete annoys a
subnetwork a data the situation is a
much more complicate they this estimate
does not work so basically suppose that
we experimental data is for the entire
network this is a situation so we have a
true positive but they were false
positive false negative with a two- they
this process is a true count this is
observed but now we only have a
subnetwork data what we observe actually
is a part of this picture this is water
we observed okay this small part plus
this small pot there is because of this
that this does not work then we prove
that the meaning of this estimate
actually you call these we know this one
is close to one is where the piece small
so then this is a reasonable is the Y
minus this missing link read the spirit
increase the power this is a number of
nodes in the motives so this also
reasonable well however we have to
address this extra term in these
formulas but this one depend on the
number of noting in terror network
depend on this to reach also depend on
the the true count of the sub motives of
the motive under the consideration so
therefore you can see this does now work
for estimated ease so therefore from
this formula that we we derive this
estimator basically we ignore this term
that we move this to this side are they
/ this constant so that this is a
formula
this is a is quite complicated so we
only validated of the estimate using the
simulations so basically we considered
ephrata random Network models so there's
a provincial attachment of model
duplication model they also ER models
they also Jimmy geometries 3d models
this is some figures to show that the
estimator actually is quite good so
basically this is a number of a note in
the random networks this is the measure
the performance of the estimator so
therefore you can see this is a way the
dumbo notre get a bigger so that is
close to zero so this so they actually
so I measure the ratio that minus one so
the so then this one is so this they
said a number of different parameters of
all the models so this one says so if we
select a mole note you see we observe
the data for a lots of network and then
this performs the better so this is the
ideas so this is just a show ok if this
the arrow reaches a high ladies does not
work ok so specifically this see this is
so this is a for a different model this
is another exemptions so therefore
basically this is the estimate or
approved based on the formula we can
derive these formulas for each motive so
this is a for the PPI networks its own
director network this is the motivator
for the director
the network's they said a so this is
there's more formulas for this as you
can see basically the formula involves
the terms for the sober network subah
motifs appearing and indeed before that
so this is the formulas we reported in
the work so based on this we use the
data that this is the estimation of the
the motive account for these
transcription factor networks so the in
summary so basically these sees the stem
cell has a smallest emotive account
relative to the network size also the
feed-forward loop counties about ten
times that of the feedback loops so this
one is a consistent with the other works
basically so this so if the feet of for
the low pay is over-represented in the
network about feedback loop is on the
representative the network it's more
interesting if we estimated this count
for ppi networks because of a ppi
networks we have this kind of error rate
so that is the derivative were derived
from the sub publish neat reach the
based on this this is over analysis ok
they compared with the earlier analysis
that this is another analysis so
basically you can see for the server
vicious over and the estimate is a lower
than the other estimate but for the
other four models overestimation a
larger than the others so this is they
also we this is the youth thing over
formula we k estimated a down bow
for the motives the motives there is
afraid of our this is a easy the
triangles okay so we have these numbers
so basically so we have this simple
observation the number of triangles in
human ppl network is 194 times that of a
yeast okay so as of the network's maybe
it's really different in your data yes
it is the size are different yeah yeah
so therefore we talked about the
triangle desti so that it looks quite
single I
yes it's a it's a price similar that
that's testing except today so I think
that's all I want to ok confidence value
did you calculate the associated with
these intervals this one yes I'm hoping
this fear like Homo sapiens of the top
table for example the spotlight yeah
yeah they say with each other they're so
far away yeah yes they say that this is
a problem but I actually you see this is
a tool for all the highest emissions we
cannot avoid this ya think that I think
I should stop here basically just
present the overworked on this to us
factor the for multi of accounting i
think that the numbers are probably not
reliable but i think over formulas are
quite interesting thank you
can easily try your father's people they
totally understand realistic assumption
of our leaders I have no idea but you
can try so so basically we have to
consider the error rate or the the two
error rate so and is there anything no
in the literature of all these risks and
the the return 0 for 4 the ppi network
the busy it's also estimated using the
gold standard the data so is no it's
also maybe this there's everything I
rated okay also as I understand you're
assuming uniform error rate across all
the possibility interactions rather than
unique error rate for each interaction
one right right that's right well it's
just a rough estimation so is if you'll
consider the error rate for each
specific a link i think i don't know how
to derive the formula
randomized networks you try to include
these correction factors not all models
to really see if that we we we have no
doubt that up i think this is a good
question but i said i think it's
interesting to see whether there's a
difference or not so maybe some motive
is over-represented in the the current
data is not in the entire network but we
have not done anything about this thank
you so much again they have another
patchy sure cut out of the box but have
you thought about applying this to
ecology so there's interaction networks
or like relationships between species
and if you go out and observe some
ecosystems a lot of species that are
they are not observed you know you under
me it really is interesting by I never
saw top of these oh okay thank you